if you're eager to travel and see the
world beyond the four walls of your home
i'm right there with you so i asked my
friend caroline to plan a road trip that
will dare me and all of us to see the us
in a new way i'm jenna lorenzo and this
is travel dares season us
[Music]
on this season of travel dares i'm on a
mission to find the most interesting
unexpected and unique destinations
america has to offer my first stop right
here in williamsburg known worldwide for
its historical reenactments of american
colonial life but my friend caroline has
planned for me to see a different side
of the city and i can't wait to find out
where we're headed let's give her a call
[Music]
hey caroline hey how are you i'm good
how are you
i'm good and so excited for you what is
going through your head
i'm just so excited to go on a road trip
yay well are you ready for your first
clue i'm very ready for my first clue
okay so your clue is commander in chief
or bust interesting uh that sounds
presidential it could be
it could not be but i'm not gonna give
you anything else just gonna have you go
for it thank you so much i'm so excited
awesome
bye have fun bye
the heck is that
hey
hello jenna how are you good this is
incredible welcome to the ruins of
presidents park is this the most unique
place you've ever seen it's the most
something i've ever seen well come on
let me show you around
[Music]
so i can tell by the look on your face
that you've got questions may i give you
a little background as to what you're
looking at yes
all right so here is the history of this
place there was a sculptor by the name
of david addicts who became inspired to
create all of these statues after he
visited mount rushmore he and some
others created three sets of these this
particular set of sculptures was in a
park about 12 miles from here called
presidents park and it was functional
from about 2004 until 2010 and then
another company came in
and purchased the property the owner of
the heads right now ended up being
commissioned to come put these in a
stone crusher can you imagine being
asked to destroy
42 beautiful sculptures of the american
u.s presidents that would be an
interesting ask that was so fortunately
for all of us he ended up declining and
figuring out a way to salvage them
specifically what he did you can see all
of them have holes in the tops of their
heads is that how they were transported
here that's what he did is he took
chains attached him to that rebar on the
inside hooked it up to the end of his
excavator
rocked them off of their massive blue
foundations put them up onto a flatbed
and then strapped them down one by one
on a bunch of tires and then over the
course of about three weeks with a crew
of six he saved them
now that you've got a history of this
place let me walk you around a little
bit to give you some individual facts
about some of the presidents okay and
there actually might be a pop quiz at
the end so pay attention uh
should i be taking notes that's not a
bad idea
so jenna the question that always comes
up from our guest is how did the owner
decide to lay him out the way he did
you'll notice that 39 of the heads are
clustered over there and then three of
the heads are separate here everybody
understands
and appreciates why george washington is
there and where abe lincoln is there but
i got a lot of questions as to how
andrew jackson made it front and center
yeah so i finally went to the owner and
asked him how andrew jackson got the
prime spot on the property and he
basically told him because he has a man
crush on him he likes the way he looks i
like that answer that's why he's there
so his nickname was old hickory because
he was as tough as old hickory oh i
think that's yeah quite the nickname
george washington most people don't know
that he was a redhead wait hold on he
was a redhead it was a redhead that is
not a wig he powdered his hair
and abe how tall do you think he was
just guess
statuesque very much so six foot four my
height so he actually was the tallest of
all of our presidents so obviously they
all have interesting facts associated
with them all before we go over and talk
about the 39 heads over there i want to
bring you over to abraham lincoln and
show you something really interesting
all right cool all right come on over
so everybody always asks why abraham
lincoln is missing the back of his head
as that excavator was lifting abraham
onto the flatbed to have him moved here
he fell backwards off the flat back
what are the chances what are the
chances he's the only one that incurred
damage during transport let me show you
a couple other things walk this way with
me here yeah so couple interesting facts
here that is gerald ford and what a lot
of people don't know about him is that
he was a male
model
teddy roosevelt did you know that he was
fifth cousins with fdr i did not know
that a lot of people don't so speaking
of woodrow wilson he was another
virginia-born president the only
president to ever earn a phd ronald
reagan
there he is
remember him he's missing an eyebrow he
is he was struck by lightning what in
real life or the statue just a statue
okay well that's good enough
so what do you think cool i mean this is
incredible good it was not a bust
i love hearing it it was a
presidential
should we say victory victory absolutely
but remember when you first arrived i
told you there might be a pop quiz at
the end ah and there's the bust let's
come on out i'm going to quiz you on a
few follow me
time to test your presidential knowledge
you ready for some trivia uh
yeah let's do it all right we're gonna
start with an easy one
all right
what color was george washington's hair
he's a redhead boom
nice job thank you so much number two
this is a little more difficult yeah
i told you andrew jackson's nickname
yeah do you remember it
old hickory boom it just sounded like a
spice that i wanted to add to my tea or
something okay
two for two
this is kind of easy maybe not i told
you who the tallest president was do you
remember who it was lincoln abraham
lincoln six foot four
three for three
smartest president the only one to ever
get a phd
you're looking in the right direction
is it roosevelt close
close woodrow wilson that doesn't feel
close that's okay it doesn't even seem
like it rhymes that's okay
[Music]
i had such an amazing time at
president's park today john
so knowledgeable so full of history and
facts
stumped me on a few questions but i
definitely made my history teacher proud
it was an incredible experience so
unique there's nowhere in this world
like it i had no idea what i was getting
into honestly it's just one of those
places you have to check out yourself
and here we go the clue for the next
episode let's see use your fingers to
hand craft a piece of pre-colonial
history
all right all right well we're in
colonial williamsburg now we're going
somewhere pre-colonial
i have no idea what that means but i'm
like really excited we'll just have to
tune into the next episode to see where
we're going next
[Music]
you